Et bien bonjour tout le monde j'espère que cette vidéo va vous plaire !
Passez-vous une bonne journée actuellement ?
Nouvelle vidéo, nouvelle thématique !
Aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de quelque chose que j'adore, et que mon papa m'a transmis !
Et oui ça vient de lui ! Je ne veux pas m'approprier ce qui ne m'appartient pas.
Les documentaires reportages animaliers.
Ahhh ! Quelle belle histoire d'amour !
Je suis pas le seul en vrai à aimer ça. Autour de moi, j'ai pas mal de gens qui aiment la nature
et qui du coup aiment bien se renseigner sur la nature et qui du coup regardent des reportages sur les animaux.
Et c'est vraiment intéressant ! Alors des fois c'est très triste la nature est très brutal (à l'anglaise) !
Nature is wild ! Comme on dit.
Mais d'autres fois y'a juste des situations qui sont un peu rigolotes.
Alors aujourd'hui, j'ai fait une petite sélection des vidéos du net du monde animal qui me font vraiment marrer.
J'aimerais vous les présenter.
Après si vous n'êtes pas sensibles au monde animal, aux animaux, etc...
C'est pas une vidéo que vous allez forcément aimer, mais en vrai on a tous notre petite sensibilité.
Ne mentez pas !
Vous n'êtes pas insensible à un animal qui possède des poils ou une peau écaillée ou ça dépend...
C'est les goûts et les couleurs mais voilà, ça vous touche forcément quelque part.
Allez on y va !
Première vidéo, je vous fais un petit topo parce que celle là, elle peut être impressionnante quand même au premier abord.
C'est un putain de serpent qui est monté sur un putain de câble électrique pour manger un putain d'oiseau.
Nous on fait un deliveroo ! Le serpent il fait tout ça pour manger mec !
Ça a un côté rigolo quand même ! Non mais qu'on se le dise... Regardez le !
Il a repéré sa proie. Sa proie l'a repéré aussi ! Elle se dit : "Mais ! C'est inhabituel de voir ça !
Qu'est ce qui lui prend à ce serpent ? Depuis des décennies nous sommes à l'abri moi et mes congénères, sur ce câble !
Mais aujourd'hui ils ont compris ! Ils se sont adaptés !"
Franchement, je veux pas te dégoûter Monsieur le serpent, mais tu n'as vraiment 0% de chance d'y arriver.
Zé-ro ! Car la cible que tu as choisi possède des ailes et peut vraiment te fuir en très peu de temps.
Ooooh ! Mon dieuuu ! On remet cette scène au ralenti !
Et c'est Jacques l'oiseau qui est venu immédiatement becqueter une petite écaille du serpent
pour lui montrer qui est le patron ! Qui est le propriétaire de ce câble électrique !
Waouh ! Hey la provocation gratuite mec qu'il a fait ! C'est incroyable !
Ohhhh... non !
Non mais t'es pas dans ton élément là !
En vrai c'est un peu triste, ça veut dire que ce serpent il a pas de nourriture au sol,
y'a plus de nourriture, y'a plus de proies pour lui au sol, probablement à cause de l'humain,
donc il est obligé de grimper sur un câble pour trouver sa bouffe quoi.
C'est un peu triste.
Et bientôt, on retrouvera Jacques l'oiseau dans un terrier pour lapin ! La nature est déréglée, totalement !
Voilà ! C'était une petite mise en haleine, là c'est soft, c'est un peu bizarre mais c'est... tranquille !
On passe maintenant à une qui a un peu plus tournée...
Souvent y'a des vidéos comme ça d'animaux qui font des dizaines, voire même des centaines de millions de vues, pour certaines !
La plus connue étant celle de l'iguane qui se fait chasser par des serpents et qui s'en sort miraculeusement,
avec une dégaine incroyable !
Je mettrai le lien en description, on va pas la regarder parce qu'elle est beaucoup trop connue.
Mais y'en a une là, qui est aussi pas mal connue et qui est très amusante !
En plus c'est des mammifères donc, je sais pas, on s'identifie plus à des mammifères je trouve, c'est encore plus touchant.
Il s'agit d'un bébé lion, d'un lionceau qui fait de la merde.
Il faut arrêter les voix off sur les vidéos comprenant des animaux.
Il faut faire un référendum. Emmanuel Macron, s'il vous plaît, chargez vous en !
On ne veut plus de gens qui font la voix des animaux sur les vidéos.
Sauf celle là ! *rire*
Mais les voix humaines là... Non arrêtez ! Arrêtez ! C'est vidéo gag ! C'est 2002 ! On arrête !
Ici on a un groupe de lions
et ici on a un groupe d'oiseaux.
Et le groupe de lions veut bouffer le groupe d'oiseaux. Bien entendu !
Ils sont en contrebas sur ce qui s'apparente être de l'herbe,
mais en fait c'est pas de l'herbe !
Et ça tous les lions ils l'ont compris !
Sauf un...
Et il va très vite comprendre !
Il s'approche donc. Il saute...
Et il se retrouve à nager ! Le con ! Et qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans cette eau ?
Un hippopotame ! L'une des espèces animales les plus énervées de la nature !
En plus il a une touffe mec d'herbes là sur le crane, c'est incroyable !
Et le lion, bien entendu, avec l'agilité d'un félin, va finalement réussir à remonter sous le regard des autres lions ...
qui l'aident totalement ! Regardez ! Ils sont en train de l'aider. Ils font ce qu'ils peuvent.
Et vous voyez ? En sortant de cette épreuve, ce lion deviendra un dangereux prédateur de la nature ! Comme celui-ci :
Troisième vidéo
Hey ! Je vous jure, je suis vraiment content de vous montrer ça !
C'est des délires mon gars ! Des fois, je passe deux heures à regarder ça comme ça
et je regarde derrière moi si personne m'a vu puisque j'ai :
"Et j'assume" et "J'assume pas trop" ! C'est très bizarre !
Troisième vidéo, encore de la bbc ! Bah t'façons c'est les number one, en contenu trop cool sur les animaux,
ils sont INTESTABLES !
Bon, là on regarde des petites bêtises, des extraits, des minis extraits de reportages qui eux, durent une heure et demie quoi.
Mais y'a vraiment des séries euuuh passionnantes !
Je vous mettrais quelques réfs dans la description pour ceux que ça intéresse.
Voilà ! Continuons notre épopée animalière !
Ahh ça fait ça ! Ça fait exactement ça ! Je sais !
Mais vous allez voir, ça va vous réconcilier un peu avec les araignées.
Je vous en fais la promesse.
Regardez ! Donc cette araignée a trouvé un bigorneau.
Pas Squeezie, un autre bigorneau. Et c'est trop mignon, mec, parce qu'elle va utiliser ce petit bigorneau
qu'elle a trouvé, pour se construire un abri. Et je trouve ça fou, qu'une araignée s'adapte comme ça
à ce qui l'entoure, genre elle a besoin d'un petit cocon chaud, mignon, pour passer la nuit,
et elle utilise un truc qu'elle a trouvé pour le construire. C'est fou !
Elle va hisser le coquillage à côté d'une branche. Regardez ! Elle tisse sa petite toile comme il faut.
J'aime pas les araignées mais là je trouve ça mignon !
Bon là elle panique un peu, elle gère pas de ouf.
Ça c'est toi en TPE, totalement !
P'tain c'est une architecte gros ! Regarde ! Regarde le time-lapse, c'est magnifique !
Eeeeeet
Hop ! Elle dort dedans ! Est ce que maintenant vous allez vous méfier de tous les bigorneaux que vous croiserez ?
Ouiiiiii !
En vrai, chaque truc où y'a un trou, où un animal peut y voir un abri, veut dire qu'il y a peut-être, un animal à l'intérieur.
Et ça je savais pas avant d'avoir vu cette vidéo ! La morale c'est : "Méfiez-vous des bigorneaux !"
Alors ça !
Wouaaahou !
Il faut savoir que dans la nature il y a des espèces animales qui ont des capacités qui sont vraiment extraordinaires.
Y'a ,par exemple, Laxolotl, vous connaissez, je parle pas du youtubeur Patrick Baud qui est génial,
je parle de l'animal qui est presque aussi génial. Donc lui, il s'adapte à son milieu naturel.
Si on le met dans l'eau ou si on le met dans un terrarium, il évolue différemment, et surtout,
il a des capacités régénératrices !? Je ne sais pas comment ça s'appelle, mais en gros, quand tu lui coupes une patte,
elle repousse quoi. Ce qui est assez incroyable ! Et là, il n'est pas question de se régénérer mais il est question de s'adapter
face à des situations, mais s'adapter en mode violent !
Regardez ! J'étais sur le cul quand j'ai découvert ça.
Là c'est National Geographic qui nous propose cette vidéo.
C'est bien de citer les sources et comme ça je mettrai toutes ces chaînes là en description,
encore une fois si vous voulez faire des petits tours et vous documenter sur la nature, c'est passionnant !
Oh un bernard l'hermite ! C'est trop mignon !
C'est bon pour vous ?? Ce n'est pas un bernard l'hermite !!
C'est une putain de pieuvre mec ! C'est une putain de pieuvre mec qui a appris à imiter le bernard l'hermite.
Pour faire face à des situations bien précises. C'est pas incroyable mec ?
Moi je sais pas me transformer en plante quand je veux pas être vu à un endroit. Je sais pas.
En plus, elle imite vraiment bien. Elle bouge ses tentacules à l'avant comme un bernard l'hermite ferait
et elle met deux tentacules pour imiter ses yeux qu'elle bouge pareil.
Et c'est vraiment troublant ! Moi je tombe dans le panneau direct !
Elle le fait pour se défendre de ses prédateurs, du coup, ses prédateurs croient qu'il y a un crustacé,
et ils en veulent pas. Ils veulent bouffer des pieuvres ou des poissons.
Ou alors à l'inverse, quand elle veut bouffer, elle, des petits poissons,
les poissons ils se méfient pas des bernard l'hermite puisque les bernard l'hermite ne mangent pas des poissons,
et du coup elles vont en profiter pour... CLAC !
Niquer le poisson dès qu'il s'approche un peu trop. Sacré céphalopode n'est ce pas ?
Alors vidéo suivante !
Ok ! Maintenant, je vais vous parler d'une chaîne youtube, qui est l'une de mes chaînes préférées de youtube
et qui est assez vieille maintenant ! Qui s'appelle : le zapping sauvage!
C'est FranceTV qui propose ça, et c'est du très très bon contenu. Merci FranceTV d'ailleurs de financer ça !
Parce que je trouve que sur Youtube, il manque un truc de la part des Youtubeurs,
c'est ce genre d'images, ce genre de trucs.
Ils ont beaucoup beaucoup de vidéos sur cette chaîne là d'ailleurs ils ont un million d'abonnés et
il y en a vraiment, certaines, qui m'ont fait chialer de rire. Et l'une d'entre elles, est la suivante :
C'est un reportage sur des crabes géants, sur une île, et en fait c'est des crabes qui volent les habitants. Et....
Regardez ! C'est incroyable !
C'est sur l'île Christmas !
(voix femme) "Sur l'une des îles les plus reculées d'Australie..."
En Australie bien sûr ! Bien sûr, bien sûr ! Tout ce qui est animaux improbables c'est en Australie, on sait bien !
"Quand je suis arrivé sur l'île, j'entendais frapper, gratter, en plein milieu de la nuit.
On croyait que la maison était hantée."
Hmm
"J'ai posé mon sac par terre, comme je l'aurais fait n'importe où ailleurs. Je suis allé faire un tour,
et quand je suis revenu, mon sac avait disparu. Il l'avait ouvert, il avait abandonné mon appareil photo, et volé ma bouteille d'eau."
Regardez-la réal de ce documentaire !, Elle n'est pas incroyable sans déconner ?
Les plans sur les vieux crochets là !
(voix de Gollum) J'arriiiiveuuh !
(voix de Gollum) C'est à moi ça ! Ne laisse pas traîner tes affaiiires ! Hé hé hé
(voix femme)" L'auteur de ces vols à répétition...
est le crabe des cocotiers."
WAOUUUH !
Quel colosse ! Il soulève clairement plus de fonte que nous !
(voix femme) "Armé de pinces capable d'ouvrir une noix de coco en deux..."
Waouuh ! Il a un décapsuleur à son compte en plus !
(voix femme) "Pour ne pas mourir de faim, ils n'ont pas d'autres choix que de chaparder."
Bon le fond de l'histoire un peu triste. C'est qu'ils crèvent la dalle ! Ils crèvent littéralement la dalle,
et du coup, ils ont compris que dans les maisons des humains il y avait à bouffer,
et ils sont malins et ils s'introduisent pour voler la bouffe.
Putain ! Mais ,mec, t'imagines tu rentres chez toi et y'a ça quoi ! Faut être sacrément serein quand même !
(voix femme) "Ils ne se cantonnent pas à des aliments comestibles."
Et regardez le lui ! Il fait ses comptes ! C'est un crabe expert comptable mec ! Ça n'a aucun sens !
(voix femme) "Ils dérobent absolument tout. Des chaussures laissées devant la porte, aux couverts oubliés sur la table.
Un crabe aurait même volé une arme à un militaire."
WOUOH ! Je pense qu'il est évident qu'on sous estime les arthropodes. CLAIREMENT !
Attendez ! Lui, il a un putain de couteau mec ! Imagine tu marches sur son frère sans faire exprès,
le crabe il te plante quoi, directement ! Y'a pas de question !
(voix de Gollum) Personne n'osera m'arrêter. Hé hé hé
(voix femme) "Max Orchard est fasciné par ces animaux et observe depuis longtemps leur étrange comportement."
En vrai, il est pas fasciné. En vrai, c'est leur otage. Les crabes ils lui ont mis le couteau sous la gorge comme ça et ils lui ont dit :
"Bon ! Tu nous mets à manger chaque matin devant la porte sinon on te plante mon pote !"
(voix femme) "Pour montrer de quoi ces crabes sont capables, il décide de leur tendre un piège avec quelques objets banals,
et des caméras à capteur de mouvement.
Il revient le lendemain pour relever les preuves."
(voix homme) "Très bien ! Ils sont venus."
(voix femme) "Les crabes se sont montrés à la hauteur de leur réputation."
*rire*
C'est incroyable.
(voix femme) "Une fois la nuit tombée, l'un d'eux s'est même enfui avec une caméra espion."
Ils sont incroyables ces crabes ! J'en veux un ! On va le voir partir avec Natsu, comme ça, sur son dos.
Oh merde ! L'explication est assez cool. C'est juste que, quand le crabe vient et qu'il a un doute sur la comestibilité
d'un objet, il le prend et il le ramène dans un coin où il peut être tranquille le temps de l'examiner.
Alors que s'il le prend pas avec lui, bah il va se faire emmerder par d'autres crabes qui vont essayer de lui voler son butin.
Du coup ça le fait chier ! Il a compris qu'il doit s'isoler quoi !
Je trouve ça fou en fait ! Je suis touché par la capacité d'adaptation de ces animaux quoi.
D'animaux on dirait qu'ils sont pas forcément très malins, parce que nous on se croit clairement supérieur,
mais en fait, ils sont tellement malins. On sous estime tellement d'espèces, c'est ouf !
Ok ! Autre vidéo de zapping sauvage !
Allez vous abonner ! Allez vous abonner à cette chaîne, allez y ! Allez y ! Là je mets une fiche. Maintenant ! Vous le faites maintenant, vraiment !
Il s'agit d'une mante religieuse qui est sur le point de se faire bouffer par une araignée. Vous savez, dans la nature c'est comme ça.
Y'a beaucoup d'espèces qui mangent d'autres espèces pour survivre, tout simplement.
Ah bon ?
Cette espèce là elle est vraiment marrante parce qu'elle tente un bluff mon gars ! C'est très courageux de sa part.
(voix homme) "Les mantes ont une vue sur développée...
mais pas autant que les araignées sauteuses."
Regardez ! On dirait pas Lucas the spiders là ?
L'araignée là pour les enfants ! Qui a pour but justement de... qu'ils aient pas peur des araignées plus tard ?
Parce que c'est très bien les araignées pour nous. Enfin, pas toutes les espèces,
mais 90% des araignées qu'on bute, en fait, elles sont hyper utiles pour nous.
(voix homme) "Cette jeune mante ne sait pas encore voler."
Tu vas y arriver !
(voix homme) "Ses longues pattes de devant, destinées à attraper des proies, l'aident dans sa fuite."
Bien joué ! Vas-y ma grande ! Enfuis toi, vas y !
Oh là là ! C'est une araignée qui saute ! Ooooooh ! Je la vois me sauter dessus, j'ai peur !
(voix homme) "Mais elle a un secret."
Wouaaahou ! Kung fu panda !
(voix homme) "Le kung fu, façon mante religieuse.
C'est du bluff."
C'est du bluff.
(voix homme) "La mante tente simplement de paraître plus grosse et de dérouter son ennemi.
Et ça marche."
Putain ! Bravo ! Quel courage ! Bravo ! Le bluff là, incroyable ! Il faut l'inscrire au poker quoi cette mante là !
Putain !
(voix homme) "Survivre quelques heures est déjà un exploit pour un insecte qui vient..."
Je suis ému
(voix homme) "de naître."
Bravo ma grande. T'es la bosse ! Bravo !
(voix homme) "Si la chance continue à lui sourire..."
Mais oui !
(voix homme) "Dans deux mois, la jeune mante orchidée sera grande et belle, comme celle qui se tient devant elle."
Wouaaah. C'est ça ! Elle a trouvé une copine.
(voix homme) "Mais on ne peut pas gagner à tous les coups.
Les mantes sont cannibales."
Aaaaah !
Eh bien les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur ces petites séquences animalières qui me...
qui me font vraiment kiffer.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu et si vous êtes fan de ce délire là,
euh bah checkez la description encore une fois, ou à l'inverse, donnez moi des trucs à regarder,
que peut-être je n'ai pas vu. Je suis très content d'avoir parlé de la nature et des animaux dans cette vidéo.
Décidément on n'arrête pas ce moment !
Je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien !
Oh putain ! J'ai envie de regarder des reportages animaliers toute la journée maintenant !
*rire*
Ça donne trop envie ces conneries !